à marseille occupation du théâtre la
criée pour protester contre la réforme
de l'assurance chômage
malgré la réouverture des lieux
culturels le 19 mai la reprise des
spectacles à la scène nationale de
marseille n'est pas encore à l'ordre du
jour depuis le 1er mai dernier les
manifestants occupent non seulement le
hall mais aussi la grande salle du
théâtre empêchant pour le moment toute
reprise des spectacles une manifestation
est organisée samedi alors que la
réforme doit entrer normalement en
vigueur le 1er juillet
j'ai pas de boulot je suis l'un des
premiers concernés je suis là je veux
travailler vraiment c'est douloureux de
se réveiller le matin et de se sentir
inutile et pas désiré et de ne pas
travailler et donc on bloque pas pour le
plaisir on bloque parce qu'il ya une
véritable une véritable nécessité et il
faut que les gens là comprennent c'est
que si ce sont des précaires ce ne sont
pas que des personnes en vacances qui
cherchent à occuper leur temps libre
c'est des gens dans la difficulté qu'ils
savent pas comment bouffe et qui savent
pas comment finir le mois c'est des gens
urgence sociale là aujourd'hui me sens
fatigué en colère toujours plus qu'au
début je dirais met dans une colère
beaucoup plus réfléchis beaucoup plus
enfin je trouve que c'est une colère
plutôt saine parce qu'elle me donne
aussi du ce et
et en colère contre voilà que ces
revendications qui ne sont pas entendus
le silence total du gouvernement dérange
beaucoup à rester ici occuper les
théâtres les opéras ont tous envie de
reprendre ce qui est complètement le
compréhensible et nous aussi on veut que
les spectacles prennent et on veut que
les artistes jouent seulement on a tout
un tas de revendications qui n'ont pas
encore été entendues par le gouvernement
et on a dit on a annoncé depuis le début
de l'occupation
partout en france on ne quitteraient pas
les lieux tant que nos revendications
n'auront pas été satisfaites et qu'on ne
veut pas de réouverture sans droits
sociaux